it was a tough start to the season for
marco his first two starts of the year
he was roughed up 12 runs over about 10
innings worth of work but if you look at
his final three starts before
unfortunately landing on the injured
list mike he really
settled down got back into a groove
murphy's setting up away
caught on and missed marco with a very
quick
tidy efficient one two three top of the
first
well the a's need to have chris bassett
do what he's done
since the beginning of the season he
started out 0-2
then at arizona won his game and then of
course
culminated with that shutout in his last
start 5-2
chris bassett that's a swing and a miss
bassett has a
up three down ending with the strikeout
no score after one
matt olsen back down on the fourth spot
in the lineup
and he drives one left field that's it
well going back there's trommel and
that baby's gone third time olson is
homered in his career off marco gonzalez
and the a's grab a one-nothing lead and
somewhere brody brazil is saying well
there's one of a whole bunch
called it well matt olson just a smart
hitter he knows what it's like to go to
the opposite field
he's done it before against this
left-hander
2-2 to murphy cut on and missed
good curve ball from marco his second
punch out
[Applause]
here look at the breaking ball so he's
using all of his pitches no problem
there 73
miles an hour at the bottom of the zone
i think the other thing that marco has
it's just that
that mentality he's not scared of
anybody goes after everybody
next pitch fastball swing and a miss by
chapman for strike three so back-to-back
strikeouts
for marco gonzalez he now has three on
the night
two outs here on the top of any number
two and he stayed with that fastball
danny up it away
yeah and that's the mentality we're
talking about a lead off homer to olson
and he comes back with two punch outs
you can get yourself in the scoring
position in front
of a guy like mitch haniger who has 35
rbis on the year
good count for mitch 2-0 bassett checks
the runner and the pitch
swing on hammered left field and that
thing is going to hit the base of the
fence scoring easily is j.p
crawford digging for second in standing
mitch henniger we got a tie ball game in
1-1 here in the third
[ __ ] hammer and hanny with his 14th
double
the extra bass hits keep on coming for
hanukkah as seeger climbs in
go ahead run it second base that's
haniger
plugging to the gap kyle seeger big
backs getting it done in the third
inning
first hannigar and now seeger with a
stand-up ribby double
2-1 mariners for kyle it's time for him
to get going again especially since
lewis now is on the injured list they're
really going to need him they always do
he's
the left-handed bat in their lineup they
count on so that's a good sign
three straight two out base hits for the
mariners
leads to a couple of runs and the lead
ty france now batting
shot down the left field line and a bear
ball
seeger gliding home france into second
on a ground rule rbi double how about
three straight ribby doubles for the
mariners who now lead it three to one
if you're keeping score at home you know
how good that looks in your scorecard
two outs single stolen base rbi double
rbi double rbi double
marco ahead is one two cut on and missed
curveball gets murphy fifth punch on for
marco
would not have guessed that he would
have a chance to match his season high
in strikeouts today but that is where he
is at right now
he's one shy
he's one two strike three
caught at the kneecaps how about six
punch-outs for marco in his return
tramell called back up from aaa tacoma
where he was
carrying it up down there with tacoma
wow this is hit
tagged out to right field taylor tremail
welcome back i will be really curious to
see
where this young man goes talking about
struggling he struggled his first time
through they sent him back to
aaa he was hot down there and here he is
in his first start being called up
the ball pretty well his first time up
he's able to shorten up that swing get
the barrel to it
426 feet he has some pop left hander out
of the stretch
lefty on lefty match up kemp waits and
santiago delivers it's swung on and
driven out to right center and deep up
the alley
and nobody's there and that's going to
go to the wall and here's elvis to
second turning in second going to third
and elvis around third he will score on
a double to right center by tony kemp
in the ace trail 4-2 and kemp continues
red hot he drills that ball up the alley
in right center
and a breaking ball in the dirt hanagar
swings and misses
throw 99 fastball inside and here comes
an 88 monarch slider
lizardo breaking out the nasty stuff
tonight huh
88 slider and the slider
sits right on the inside corner strike
three called so a hit given up by
lizardo and three strikeouts
in the bottom of the fifth in a lot of
the sliders 87
88 we talked about wanting to see
something a little softer from jesus
koenig slide to left and strike you out
and he struck out again on a breaking
ball away
all of lizardo's outs have been
via the k here's the one-two pitch swung
out of miss gets him off speed
murphy strikes out too away and that'll
bring up donovan
4-2 in the seventh
and there's a line drive headed for the
left field corner
biscotti headed for third takes a look
at katsey marcotte say the third base
coach holds him up
and the a's have second and third and
one out
so big at bat for tony kemp came through
in the fifth can he do it here in the
seventh
this one's driven right field fraley
over into right center he's got it
biscotti's going to tag come in to score
interest goes to third sacrifice fly for
kemp so he's got a couple of rbis
tonight
and now it's four to three cannon had a
double in the third he's one for three
another 3-2 slider bounce on the ground
left side of the hole
off the glove of crawford it trickles
into left field
elvis is home it's a tie game just
enough between seeger and crawford
and andrews is home it's a 4-4 contest
in the seventh inning lowry at first
pinder at second
canna at third and now zamora is gonna
get on top of the hill here to face
olson was homered
and that one is lined toward left or
toward right it's gonna fall for a hit
and the a's are gonna grab the lead with
a two-run
single by matt olsen he just kind of
chipped it out there
dropped it right over the head of the
second baseman in front of fraley and
wright and it's six to four
and he gets it fair down the third base
line another slider he stayed with it
lowry's going to come in to score
olson's being waved home
and olson's gonna score it's eight to
four
the a's have scored six times here in
the seventh inning
and look look at the front side of
murphy way out in front
down on one knee his right knee yet look
where this ball ends up
down the third base line hit hard enough
that seeger gold glover that he is could
not get to it didn't even leave his feet
him continues hot
and his average up to 263 and his on
base is almost 400
here's the 01 fish and the breaky boss
drilled the right way back
if it's ferrous gone right down the line
and gone
and tony kemp has hit it out and man is
he hot
and now the a's reach double figures
10-4
athletics in the top of the eighth tony
camp with his second home run this year
just inside the foul pole down the right
field line
i guess he's hot oh man you don't
normally see a guy that stands
five seven stay at the plate and admire
a blast
this has some punch behind it the
opposite way
what a shot by tom murphy
he can be awfully scary he's been
heating up he's really been swinging the
bat well
over the last week and a half and now he
goes opposite barrel
biscotti line drive right field and a
dive fairly in and out of the glove
lowry will score to make it 11-6. ready
here it is and it's swung on a ground
ball left side and it's
a diving play at short crawford has no
play the run scores from third
camp has five rbis the bases remain
[Applause]
loaded and that is a swing and a miss
and that is the ball game
so the a's break their three-game losing
streak and they do it with some late
offense and a huge night from tony kemp
and congratulations to
bob melvin his 799th win
as the manager of the athletics